salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione
iniziamo questo video avvicinandoci al
natale
chi mi conosce lo sa io adoro questo
periodo mi piace un sacco a girarli per
i negozi di giocattoli con un pedofilo
immergendomi dei ricordi
poi però mi viene in mente un problema
che perseguita i bambini da generazioni
i regali sbagliati quando da piccoli
volevate un regalo in particolare ma non
potevate andarlo a cercare con i vostri
genitori quindi gli diceva te voglio la
playstation e loro che non capivano una
fava ti portavano questa la polis
deshaun e mentre tu piangevi e veniva
insultato dai tuoi amici stronzi mamma e
papà ti rispondono ma tanto è la stessa
cosa
questo è il caso di little panda fighter
film della toyland video casa brasiliana
famosa per creare palesi copie di film
molto più famosi tipo the little cars
che ovviamente e cars ratatouille ying
che e ratatouille e appunto little panda
fighter che copia palesemente kung fu
panda
ma diamo un taglio a questa lunghissima
introduzione e partiamo con la trama il
film inizia con una delle peggiori
animazioni di recente memoria
datti da fare banca tra il pavimento non
si pulisce da solo santi dio sembrano le
presentazioni pre renderizzate dei
giochi degli anni 90 ed è per questo che
oggi vi presento la mia animazione
orribile sgorbio mi odia è talmente
fatto male con quattro soldi che a
doppiarlo sono io stesso con la voce
leggermente modificata pensate 160 mila
iscritti e fa ancora video di merda taci
il nostro protagonista panca da lavora
in un bar ma il suo sogno è quello di
diventare una ballerina ballerina ok io
capisco tutto capisco il voler ballare
capisco il voler mettersi quegli
scaldamuscoli rosa ma perché dando per
scontato che tu sia sano di mente
dovresti metterti una parrucca bionda
magari vuole iniziare a fare video su
youtube o out lavora in un bar in cui ci
sono degli incontri di boxe insieme alla
sua collega che giuro su dio non ho idea
di che animale dovrebbe rappresentare e
il suo capo un orso polare
intanto vediamo l'incontro tra il
campione in carica fenomeno orso e un
orsetto del cuore
o che meraviglioso attacco di pancia da
parte di tele rosso forse questo è
invece ho paura di noi signore signori è
bello vedere come un film basato sui
combattimenti sia animato di merda
l'orso polare che ha le braccia piegate
come se fosse un pupazzo è arrabbiato
perché fenomeno orso e il campione ma
non vale nulla concesso espansa dovrebbe
cambiare il suo nome è noioso rso già
hai ragione era la stessa cosa quando
combatte v.to polaris sei stato campione
per tre anni di seguito prima di
ereditare questo club e ritirarti e del
mucchio quello signore e signori vi
presento boccino il personaggio creato
per far ridere i bambini perché al mozzo
al naso e divertente avere il moccio al
naso perché tutti i bambini sono così
[ __ ] da sbudellarsi da ridere
per un naso gocciolante sto ridendo
panca da che non ha voglia di lavorare
vuole chiedere all'orso di poter uscire
prima che possa disturbarla signore è
bancata poi entrare cos'è accaduto
era veramente necessaria st scena perché
non ho fatto la grafica è così piacevole
da guardare riesce a prendere il
permesso e ne approfitta per andare dal
suo maestro di danza un poligono senza
texture che sembra essere stato
masticati e poi sputato in quella forma
prova subito a mettere tuoi vestiti per
le accettare mantra non interrompe le
mie meditazioni lizza frizzo di
soffritto si li soffritto pezzo di merda
non ho capito le scene inutili sono
interminabili e quelle che dovrebbero
essere le gag durano una frazione di
secondo
mi chiedo perché questi film non abbiano
successo io parlavo di quello che hai
dentro di tua essenza la mia essenza
starà parlando del mio profumo si annusa
le ascelle perché il maestro ha detto
essenza e lui pensava e senza il sudore
che ad offrire di bambino ridi finito
quello che sembra il dialogo più inutile
mai scritto torna al bar dall'orso che
gli mostra il costume che userà
all'incontro che è nato nuovo lottatore
rosa del mistero sembra slann der man
pelle nera attillata così se non dovesse
andare bene l'incontro ha già la
carriera pronta
ma il costume puzza quindi chiede a
panca da di lavarlo
mi rimangio tutto quello che ho detto
prima ha chiaramente la musica nel
sangue è la musica che produrrebbe un
gatto stritolato in un frullatore si
scopre che panca da si vergogna della
sua passione che mi chiedo il perché
dopo un altro noiosissimo dialogo si
torna dall orso ma panca da si dimentica
il costume nella lavatrice
sembra che se sarei stato un po e
finalmente arriva il giorno
dell'incontro ma poco prima dell'inizio
accade l'inevitabile rispettivi angoli
mi sta per cominciare
non ci posso credere ma quello è sembra
proprio bancato cosa sembra proprio
bancato sicuro sono identici a parte
qualche metro di differenza e una
ventina di chili di muscoli sono
praticamente gemelli mentre l'incontro
inizia panca da di nascosto partecipato
un'audizione di danza
non so quale delle due parti mie
emozioni di più save della standa all
erede di mohammed ali latex
lo scontro è noioso a dir poco sembra di
guardare quel giocattolo con i due
robottini che ci mettano banca da invece
se avessi un cervello mi starebbe
colando dal naso io sinceramente non so
che cazzo sia successo qui ecco da dove
ha preso ispirazione felix un piccolo
passo per l'uomo un grande passo per il
panda obeso
fatto sta che l'orso ricordo scambiato
per panca da vince l'incontro il vero
panca da invece non viene ammesso per
colpa di quello made era tutto perfetto
fino al finale non potete lasciar
correre
io penso che sia una qualità molto
apprezzabile anche se lo ha portato a
una conclusione del pezzo poco felice la
sua performance mi ha lasciato qualcosa
la dignità sono d'accordo sul fatto che
lo spirito della performance e si è
stato molto emozionante devo esprimere
il mio disaccordo l'esecuzione era in
perfetta e poco curata lo avete un
grande talento grezzo che col tempo e
l'allenamento potrebbe trasformarlo in
un grande ballerino
inoltre se accettassimo saresti il primo
panda a frequentare l'accademia su
questo abbiamo dei dubbi non credo
sarebbe positivo per te se abbiamo
capito basta il povero panda si ritorna
a casa sconsolato in un'ambientazione
talmente spoglia e triste che se avesse
le vene si ritaglierebbe sicuro
non è possibile secondo me italiano
prima no non lo fanno tutto fidati
te l'ho detto ti odio per avermi creato
solo per vedere questo aborto lo so
tornato al bar tutti gli fanno i
complimenti perché pensavano che fosse
lui polso capisce il malinteso ma finge
che sia stato veramente panca da lottare
questo è quello che credono ma noi
sappiamo che in realtà sono stato io a
battermi persino tono credi il che
ridicolo perché lo sai benissimo che lo
sta dicendo non starà cercando di
prendersi il merito della grande impresa
di panca da non si fa signor polari
invece panca da credeva che si
congratulano con lui per il saggio di
danza un maestro di dall'esatto e
l'audizione è stata un successo
insomma non è di questo che parlano
tutti vuoi dire che tu pensavi che
quello di cui tutti parlano e che noi
scusa ragazzo io scusa ragazzo questo è
davvero buona vedi io avevo proprio
capito che state parlando di mio dio ma
quante strozzo
me lo immagino alle prese con suo figlio
papà si i bambini a scuola mi prendono
in giro perché mi piace cantare senti
qua calo
avevamo britney spears in casa e non hai
detto niente se adottato
panca da confida tutto al maestro anche
che la ragazza si è innamorata di lui
solo perché ha vinto l'incontro to
combatte a decidere tra gli amici e lui
cosa decide di fare fingere di aver
lottato ma che bell'insegnamento che
diamo a chi guarda il film ei bimbi
capito se volete conquistare una donna
dovete mentire come cani e quando sarete
più grandi mi raccomando aggiungete
sempre 10 cm immaginari al vostro pene e
non solo siccome fenomeno rso indice un
altro incontro panca da decide di
lottare lui stesso e voglio essere io a
combattere con fenomeno cosa hai perso
completamente il cervello questa è la
più grossa pazzia che abbia mai sentito
ma mi sono accorto che mi piace essere
trattato da campione signor polaris ed è
per questo che voglio diventarlo davvero
ma questo è un [ __ ] scorpio non
dirle parolacce sei un [ __ ] un
[ __ ] non gli posso di stupidino
l'orso allora decide di allenarlo come
si deve
questa parte l'ho odiata mi ha dato
talmente tanto fastidio non è possibile
che ogni singolo movimento che lui
faccia abbia un suono
andiamo
immaginati il doppiatore in quelle scene
tossisca riusciranno sto panca da
sconfiggere il fenomeno rso io spero che
ci rimanga a secco
lo speriamo tutti l'incontro ha inizio
ma panca da non sembra essere in forma
signore e signori è incredibile dopo
neanche un minuto dalle mancate già al
tappeto
quando sei sul ring ti prendi tutti i
pugni che non scrivi hai capito
no grazie capitano più ci pensiamo noi
immaginandosi di precipitare dal cesr no
c'è qualcosa che non va nella testa di
sto cavolo di panda cerca di reagire 9
10 signori e signori pare proprio che
manca da sia stato messo ko dallo
sfidante fenomeno rso che ha
riacquistato il titolo viene battuto ma
è un po strano che in un film del genere
il protagonista perda così a caso ma io
lo sapevo che contro quel bestione
sarebbe stato impossibile e allora ho
scommesso tutto sulla montagna di
muscoli e questo significa che lei è
ricca
non ci credo ma quest'orso credo sia il
più grande figlio di esista sulla faccia
della terra
e ora cosa succederà
che razza di finale e questo non è un
finale per un film d'animazione questo è
un finale per un poliziesco dritto
dritto tra slevin e the departed cieli
del panda fighter e che insegnamento ci
ha lasciato o cari bambini che mentire e
sfruttare le debolezze degli altri per
diventare ricchi alle loro spalle è cosa
buona e giusta fregatevene di chi dice
il contrario i soldi sono la felicità
quindi questo era little panda fighter
lo so che essendo per bambini alcune
cose si potrebbero tralasciare mai stato
fatto nel 2007 ormai film d'animazione
sono guardabili tranquillamente anche
dagli adulti il doppiaggio è l'unica
cosa che si salva in questo scempio di
tridimensionalità
spero che la recensione vi sia piaciuta
e sgorbio poi finalmente tornare a casa
vuoi farmi un favore certo non chiamarmi
mai più per un altro video ti taglio la
faccia con una matita sei simpaticissimo
senti la prossima volta non potremmo
andarci a vedere un altro tipo di film
tv
non lo so l'ultimo della saga di
twilight breaking dawn
non ho interesse ad andarlo a vedere
perché dovrei andarlo a vedere per poi
farci una parodia ok io e te abbiamo
chiuso